like a scene out of frozen in the  mountains of Shanxi Province in northern  China by the Lewisohn mountains Nimue  ice caves a spectacle of icicles ice  Falls and eye stalagmites these caves  are thought to have formed around three  million years ago during an early Ice  Age and while there are many caves like  this around the world  the Ning mu caves are special for one  particular reason this cave stays frozen  all year long while temperatures can  reach up to 70 degrees outside in the  summer the temperature inside never  rises above 32 degrees scientists  believe this is due to the caves natural  bowling pin shape which traps cold air  inside stretching thousands of feet down  the top 300 feet are open to the public  with five layers connected by a winding  maze of ice stairs holes and bridges  established as a national park in 2005  the caves are staged with colorful  lights emphasizing the grandness of this  ancient cavern it is truly a sight to  behold